lift off
i've always been interested in space
when i was
at school
it was just the time of the big
discoveries and then when i saw the
space shuttle columbia fly for the first
time which was when i was already 19 or
20 years old that's when i knew for sure
that i wanted to become an astronaut as
well i have always been a person even as
a young girl who was fascinated by the
idea of exploration i grew up in a small
village in in the mountains so that's an
environment where parents can allow you
to go out and i think that kind of
experienced coupled together with
readings about science fiction and
exploring distant worlds really sparkled
to me this fascination
exploration is part of the human nature
and the exploration of the solar system
is part of that fulfillment we all
understand that there is a lot that we
cannot predict so the point is about
expanding what is possible then people
will pick up on that they will see the
concrete possibilities and they will
pursue it
space exploration becomes as a nursery
for the engineering that then can
benefit all the other industries in a
country
it's also about technologies that can
find applications in everyday life so
what we need really is a political will
shared by countries to do something that
will not bring immediate benefits to the
ones who take the decision building the
future is about being able to have
long-term vision to face up to big
challenges and to have the capability of
mobilizing the resources the talents the
hearts and minds of people towards that
goal in the european side we have a
stable situation for what concerns the
missions to mars in 2016 and 2018 but
the missions thereafter will require new
funding explorations has always brought
big benefits to humankind and it's very
important for societies societies that
stop exploring stop progressing the
future is not something to predict
future is something you build
i'm ready to go anyone interested
you